Chocoholics, rejoice!
Add another study to mounting evidence that chocolate is good for you.
Researchers at San Diego State University fed more than 30 lucky participants...
...either dark chocolate containing 70% cocoa...
...or white chocolate which contains no cocoa.
After 15 days, the participants who ate the dark chocolate...
...had lower blood glucose and LDL cholesterol and higher good cholesterol levels...
...compared to the white chocolate eating group.
Jacques Torres, a renowned chocolatier, has been touting chocolate's benefits for years.
Chocolate can cure common cold.
That's something that nobody knows yet.
I didn't know that.
Is that one of your research studies?
It's the best aphrodisiac in the world.
It is good for your heart and for cholesterol and all those things.
He says, above all, chocolate improves mood.
And most of us don't need a study to tell us that.